here's a cliche come to life a Silicon
Valley man who has turned his living
room into a laboratory I have my a 3d
printer I have my son dueling station I
mean I can do everything in my living
woman the tools of the inventor trade
have become kind of standard in recent
years sometimes they're used to change
the world and sometimes they're used for
well you'll see
I love Denise this is why I've done
these thinnies device what our French
friend is built is a GoPro sized umpire
that can call the lines in a tennis
match with 99% accuracy
this may not impress everyone but to a
tennis addict like me it sounds
remarkable and I have to know if the
claims were too good to be true you see
that you have a buzzer and the head
light telling you that your ball was out
at pro tournaments this type of
technology cost about eighty thousand
dollars per court now for $199 the
weekend warrior can get similar
technology and maybe put an end to nasty
line call specs so the price of a tennis
racket you can offer yourselves to send
device that you are from your
professional tournament that must be you
you hit deeper that I did part of the
reason this little device is so good is
because it runs on the same AI
algorithms found in autonomous cars from
companies like Tesla a Google finding
the players on the tennis court it's
like you're finding the pedestrian on
the
from two cameras that is on the Tesla
finding the yellow board is like finding
the circulation headlight Gregoire has
never had a blockbuster but he's done
well enough half a dozen inventions to
maintain this lifestyle his no-frills
lab runs on sweat and toil and whatever
he gets interested in next there are
those players who love to cheat and
fight on the tennis court bless them for
the rest of us the in out could just
further the love of the game
[Music]